ladies and gentlemen please welcome
Molly Ringwald and Matthew Broderick
in life there is always that special
person who shapes who you are who helps
you determine the person you become for
me that person was John Hughes a
brilliant writer director and friend who
saw something in me at the age of 16
that I didn't even see in myself but
John saw something in all of us his
genius was taking the pain of growing up
and relating it to everyone his gift was
creating characters stories and truths
about being a teen and bringing them to
film in a way that no one had ever done
before it is why his influence endures
as an actor I just listened to John and
I did whatever he told me and thanks to
him for the last 25 years nearly every
day someone comes up to me taps me on
the shoulder and says hey Farris is this
your day off
to me to me John was a friend and a
mentor a private man a family man and in
his own quiet way one of the funniest
human beings I've ever met Bueller
Bueller how could I possibly be expected
to handle school in a day like this
what is so dangerous about a character
like Ferris Bueller is he gives good
kids bad ideas last night at the dance
mother brother paid a buck to see ur
underwear
why are you holding my hand
where's your other hand to cling to
pillows
I was aren't allowed I based a lot of
all my material in my pictures on my
life my childhood this is my house I
have to defend it it is so important for
you to belong to send at that age if
you're trying to identify himself who am
what where do I fit I belong and all
this that pressure to belong so enormous
I hate feeling a shame
I hate I'm so isn't mean I don't way to
take me home okay
why because I don't want you to see
where I live okay are you only 18 years
old then I'm 19 and I'm 20 when does my
life belong to me you want to get
married I'm not getting married
give me one good reason why not I'll
give you two good reasons why not my
mother and my father my god are we gonna
be like our parents not me it's
unavoidable
just happens what happens and you got
your heart dies who cares I care do you
think I'm gonna be happy I mean honestly
maybe we'll work out who knows yeah
you'll be happy you just won't know it
that's all
ever
yep I said it before and I'll say it
again life moves pretty fast you don't
stop and look around once in a while you
could miss it
ladies and gentlemen Jon Cryer Anthony
Michael Hall Judd Nelson Ally Sheedy and
Macaulay Culkin
John created characters that were at
once familiar almost painfully ordinary
but at the same time transcendent and
iconic John gave us all the gift of
laughter and understanding he had a gift
for treating young people not as
children but as developing adults when
you get older your heart dies ironic
words written by modern-day Peter Pan a
man who refused to get older John always
treated me with dignity even the tiny
nine-year-old version of myself because
that's what he did he treated people
with respect with us tonight in our
audience our members of John's family
his wife Nancy John the third James
Tracy
Andrew de
thank you thank you for coming and Jeong
danke Schoen